so you are about to watch a super fun
let's tournament I played recently where
I had one ground rule for myself was to
play a different aggressive Gambit in
every single game and as you'll see the
games did not disappoint uh I had every
single crazy Gambit you could think of
from Halloween to lafian to some made up
gambits even play the computer cheater
which you'll see how that unfolds and I
saved the craziest Gambit for the final
game in this tournament so I've gone
ahead and time stamped every single game
in the video description feel free to
hop around at your leisure but also feel
free to watch the whole thing through I
think you'll enjoy every game in this
video and before we get to the chess I
do want to give a huge thank you to
today's sponsor which is Audible and for
this ad read I am going to teleport
locations so I want to give a big thank
you to Audible for sponsoring today's
video
now you might be wondering what is this
weird habitat I am in who's this weird
creature beside me
uh this is one of my favorite places to
take a walk and listen to an audiobook
on Audible this is Roxy by the way Roxy
say hi say hi
now if you're not familiar with audible
they are a massive audiobook platform
have everything spoken word
entertainment uh whatever you're into
whether it's fiction non-fiction
business self-development you can find
something that Peaks your interest on
Audible and I'm super excited to
recommend one of my new all-time
favorite audiobooks that I just
discovered recently and binge the whole
thing in just a few days uh the
audiobook is called my name is Tani and
I believe in miracles it's an incredible
story of a young chess player Tani arumi
who was a Nigerian Refugee and moved to
U.S was living out of a homeless shelter
and ultimately won the New York state
championship he made world headlines a
few years ago and his story is told in
just amazing audiobook it's so well
produced the narration is great
now if you want to try Audible for free
for 30 days and get any audiobook of
your choice I do have a special offer
for my viewers you can click the link in
the video description audible.com I am
Rosen or text I am Rosen to 500 500 and
start listening today thanks again to
Audible for sponsoring today's video and
now let's get back to some chess
also get back to chasing squirrels right
right Roxy
and here we go
I'm black
so Stafford Dark Knight
Troxler
opponent is not present
uh oh
no my opponent I think the time just
starts ticking right
yeah they have
they have two minutes and 55 seconds to
make a move
yeah this first game is the opponent
Gambit
my opponent has already been sacrificed
or maybe their Wi-Fi has been sacrificed
also officially oh no my opponent
okay I got the free win
I was uh
I mean yeah that was that was the
opponent candidates
back to tournament
okay it's Gambit time a lot of the
gambits for white featured E4 opening so
I'll play amora
I was a one gambits in Sicilian that was
asked for
this is actually what I like to play as
black
uh yeah this is all standard
I think this is standard
I'll admit I don't know too much Theory
here but
I think I want to attack D6
maybe Queen E3
there's some funny night move takes
takes
okay so I'm starting to take
not sure if this actually works but it's
interesting
so if Asics I take take take and then
win back the pawn and pin the knights
yeah that's a move
I think I'm going to end up sacking on
D4
oh no my Exchange
the idea is now there's some
compensation like black has
really weak Pawns
but I am down a decent amount of
material
but this night is very hard to remove
so it's a fun position to play
and this bishop is sad
which makes me happy
okay I think I want to play like
H3 might not be necessary
it's hard for black to even threaten
like back ring mates Quincy it might be
coming
but I think I can go ahead and do this
and then if Queen C8 I take
wow
it's a bold decision
play Rook T1
idea of Rook lifting
okay now the queen is tied down to the
bishop Bishop has no legal moves
dad this still looks really really fun
my knight is kind of pinned to the queen
but that's okay
yeah I can't quite Rook lift I could
play this move
like making lufts
and now
maybe I should play A3
of the bishoper square to move back to
there's some idea to play Bishop B1 and
E5
and then eventually checkmates like E5
immediately
how to do this
yeah I want to play E5 next
still not crystal clear
take
so if I play E5
it's getting spicy
it's getting really spicy
so I'm threatening to take
Queen moves here I still take
and the dream is to Checkmate on each
seven which
is about to turn into a reality
F2
that's one check and King F1
oh it's not so simple though
or is it
yeah this might be okay for black
there's one move here
okay I don't think that's the move I was
more scared of Queen H4
okay
I think Queen H4 is
maybe winning for black
I have Knight F6 but King h8 same thing
with 97
am I losing here
wow Queen H4 is just winning for lack
that could have been a cool defensive
idea to like take and then defend the
x-ray vision on the H file okay so let's
keep notes round one was opponent's
candidates
round two was Smith Mora
very Sicilian
okay it's Gaba time
there's no berserking in the Swiss
tournament
like everyone plays the same number of
games
okay so I think I'll start with I mean a
Stafford why not
or one of those should I play the
corkscrew
what is a corkscrew let's let's play the
lafian
and I'll go for a corkscrew
opponent might not go for it though
but it's after Bishop here and then
I think it's Queen E7 Knight F7 then
take
like Bishop C4 Queen E7 I'm pretty sure
there's a line
okay this I'm already out of the book I
mean D6 looks playable though
okay
we have a position
probably develop the or bring back the
bishop
I think D5 makes sense it does allow 95
but then you can keep developing
that's a good move
it's actually a really annoying move
E6 takes ticks I think it's okay
foreign
ifying
F3 might come at some point
F3 has come
might have to take
actually doesn't look so bad ready to
Castle got that file there's some
pressure against the Knight
let's reinforce things maybe bishop F7
soon
that allows Knight F5 though maybe this
move
hitting each two preparing this
okay I want to do things against the
king
there's a cool line uh rookie 294
oh that doesn't work though I thought I
had Bishop H2 but the Rooks defended
maybe it's okay somehow
I might just be losing a pawn
uh check in here
I just lost a pawn at least that aligns
with my Gambit uh approach
I have opened a file
the similar file eventually
actually there is an idea to like take
in the bishop C4
so I don't know if the pawn is
capturable
because now take Knight takes
Bishop C4 uh there's 92
take take
yeah I don't think that works my
Bishop's hits
but what else to do
take
maybe it's playable let's try it
oh no it's not playable there's Queen C4
but maybe
Queen C4 leaves a night undefended now
here I have this thankfully
I'm trying to chase the bishop away now
I have Queen F4
hitting this and this
so do you have some nice initiative here
I mean queen C4 King H7
maybe it's okay
also up a lot of time
yeah the risky play is kind of paid off
up on time winning back material safe
King
what does this move
rookie one
okay
that was nice
that's a funny game
so just to explain the corkscrew
I only learned the name last night as
after this this this I don't think
leechas will recognize it as a corkscrew
but it's where you sack the rook and
then play D5 and then Bishop G4 and
black is winning here
but um
I think even stronger is Queen takes E4
here
anyway the scheme wow white was crushing
me Bishop D2 ah Bishop D2
and I can't actually attack the knights
and white has two pieces for The Rook
actually two pieces and a pawn for The
Rook
okay
I'll take it
got the lafian
okay
um
I'll see what upon plays
maybe I'll play maybe I'll go for
enactments in
oh opponent trying to grab it okay maybe
I'll go for Halloween
okay Halloween Gambit time
I think this is the first Gambit
suggested earlier
I think this is the best move
hey thank you half love gifting five
I'm pretty sure I've had this position
before
but it's been a while
I would think like the frequency of me
playing the Halloween Gambit probably
spikes in October
especially towards the end of October
I want to play Queen C6 next so Queen's
tied down to the Rook
maybe the smooth
trying to paralyze black a little bit
Queenie four
I mean I'm still down a piece
so there's some work to do
I want to push the H Pawn
do I care about my b-pawn
probably not
it's so important when you're playing
gambits like this to have a uh very
aggressive mindset
like if I don't have to play a defensive
move
I'd much rather play some move that
generates a threat
I am threatening to drop the knights
and this Knight moves might see Knight
C6
Knight C6
there's a funny line where like I allow
this and then I play like Knight B5 and
castle queenside
probably doesn't quite work
maybe could still be funny
I was thinking G4 here
wow
this is also kind of funny
so I could play F3
I think F3 makes sense
just sacking the pawn
take take
maybe I'll play this
it looks kind of risky
but I'm leaving the tension between the
Bishops
if Queen B7 I played B3 Bishop A3 King
B1
if takes takes Knight F7 eventually I
want to storm with Athan
yeah maybe you start by taking
I could play native no nothing not A4
doesn't work
uh what to do Bishop D2
sacking this Pawn
I feel like I need my Bishop to defend
the dark squares
wow
very fancy
have this move to start
ready to take the Knight
being down material for so long makes me
it makes me grateful for times when
materials actually kind of balanced
especially now when I'm on material
I take the night now
and then G7
and then take this Pawn
and then take the other Pawn
uh how to do this
I should probably move back
I do want to take H6 very soon
I want to play this soon
I don't think I care about the G4 Pawn
I gotta watch my time though
you know hitting the Rook now
maybe I could have taken verse with
Chuck
this is looking really nice
all the major pieces
cutting off the king
okay that was a successful Halloween
Halloween came a little bit early
okay so that was four rounds
68 players here it's still not too late
to join
uh approaching round five
starting in two seconds
and now let's go for a Budapest
oh uh
how do I Gambit
oh
and this is kind of a Gambit right
okay let's make up a Gambit let's play
the G5
I don't want you to do the Stonewall
gabbit
there's so much nice symmetry here
now Knight E4 hitting the pawn I want to
play H6
the problem with H6 is G6
maybe it's still fine
wow
so it's kind of like a bank open on the
king side
I can live with this
I have Queen A5 here
takes takes
it's already a funny position
takes takes six
and queen if I make some sense
because I want to win the E3 Pawn
so Knight D2 I take on E3
yeah the only way for white for black to
the for white to defend
is to take with a king
but then I'm gonna have some
how to do this
it's still not so simple
take take
I could start by taking
maybe start with this uh
I don't know
it was really conflicted there
so I'm allowing Knight P5 which is now
played I'm still down the pawn
might be ready to castle with Chuck
very strange position
I'm down the mid on the clock so I'm
counting some time as well
that's a good move
Bishop
E6 first
and Bishop D3 might be coming or not
give me five
the bishop makes sense on E5
there's some Rook H4 idea
so then later double up
okay now hitting this Pawn
if G4 I play Rook h8
uh
wow can I take that
and taking makes sense
King E3 I take on H1
yeah this looks pretty good
okay maybe I keep Brooks on the board
I want a key Center upon
character D2 idea
a nice central control here
Bishop D4 maybe next
I was almost meeting I'm gonna win the
Rook though King F1 order graph two
okay that was nice
I just made up a gavis what is this on
G5 is this a novelty
let's see leeches
has been played 42 times before
it's really hard to play a novelty based
on uh Lee chess to other days
anti-stone wall Gambit
okay next game starts in six seconds
oh you are the Asmar Gary oh wow so it's
the same Gary you just changed your name
I think that makes sense I should have
realized that
okay we'll play E4 again and this time I
will play I'll play that funny uh tennis
and gambits who takes a knight G5
wait what
uh
can I transpose
I can't transpose what is this
how do I Gambit okay I'll play E6 Maybe
I play E6 here
um
I won the soccer Queen
E6 takes
okay we're having fun
oh it's kind of dubious
but I mean
those only clear opportunities to canvas
maybe G4
G4 H for H6
yeah I don't know how much census makes
I'll just try and roll with it
at least I got some King side potential
maybe I'll Castle queenside
opponent's playing well though
I do another five
okay this is something
for maybe D4
doesn't quite work
like F4
and this first of takes I have this
King B8 expected
oh
okay this is something
can I take and then take
oh it's messy
oh this is also messy
um
taking on B7 doesn't work take the
Knight
maybe I take the Knight
an F5
shutting out the Bishops
making the pawn smile
between me here here
and there's also this move
Knight P5
play this first I'm down a minute
it's a good move too
Knight b5's coming
maybe there's some idea to like Target
the dark squares
okay
the boxes gave back the pawn
hitting this Pawn now
Tricky Tricky
hitting this Pawn
I want to put the Rook here
might be threatening to take two
I was getting weird
okay
okay we can trade everything
my pawns are so happy
yeah it's not stalemate
a G5 on Plus on
okay that was nice
that was a funny game
uh I don't even know what to call that
weird Carol Kong gambits
yeah I thought this would be like
dangerous for my reading but so far I've
been gaining a few points
um
what's it play next
I'll probably be black
um still due for a Budapest
hey it's Budapest time okay
we're the best gambits
this is a main line
opponent knows what they're doing
wait what I don't think I've ever seen
Rook D1 before
I wonder if that was a mouse slip
I wonder if this was like weird crap
huh
Queen G2
take take
that's interesting
I'm gonna lose C7
yeah I think I just got out prepped in
The Budapest
maybe it's still playable
I'm still down the pond
but no time to cry
I have to save my tears
uh there's this move
that makes sense Hit The Rook
Rook D1 Knight year threatening mate
also depending upon
okay so the plan is actually very
positional to Target this Pawn
I get Bishop D3 probably Knight C5
maybe Knight A5 soon
hey car wanna one
oh maybe I should have been following
that
I saw that they were close in the
standings
good job to Fabi
it's 92
takes takes
hmm
I feel like I should take
Rook C8
and the pawn should fall eventually
and white has an interesting option like
whether it's a castle or to develop The
Rook along the H file
and my plan is pretty clear though oh I
have to watch out for that
H6
yeah so Bishop D5 King h8 threatening
this and this
or this
Knight G3 is a triple four two
which is not easy to stop
and Rook here
and also take on F2
I think this makes some sense
let's move back
I mean based on the structure this
should be very pleasant for black
and the bishop looks strong though
I want to make sure the Knight is uh
attacking the pawn
might see this move
okay now
maybe I just take uh G6 is hanging
tick tick tick
I can take like this
now D5
not super clear
oh wow
fancy move
and G4 is a mistake
okay that was a close one man
opponent outcrops me in the Budapest I
don't really have much time to analyze
because
next game is starting really soon
uh but real real quick
what was my Improvement after Rook T1
oh I should play F6 sooner okay good to
know
okay
next game
so this is my Gambit list so far
I'm white again
playing
oh let's fight an ortho shop
Ortho Gambit time
this is a fun Gadget against the French
for a while it was like very like not so
well known like incredibly rare and then
Jonathan transfer made the video about
it
now it's a little bit more
at least a little bit more recognized
um this is one of the main lines all
right I sacked the epon have this uh
tension against F7
uh Knight D5 looks really attractive
play Knight E5 right away
ready to take on C7 Maybe
D4
let's try this and then King off Alana
if on person I play King F1
it's still not clear
foreign
Knight C5 Queen D1
going back to where I came from
but I want to play Bishop F4 with
complete destruction
wow
and take
also maybe play this move but let's take
first
foreign
I think I should just win The Rook
um looking for better though
there's 94 in the end which
a little bit unsettling
I'm not actually sure
maybe should be five
there's Rook P1
okay I think I'll play Rook P1 first
so if I took the Rook there was 94
threading this and this
okay now I can play this
oh
let's see what to do
take
93
and then Knight F3
my opponents played really well
I'm down on time
okay at least there's some conversation
maybe
I have to take with Bishop
down a ton of time here
and opening completely backfired
so I'm down three pawns and about a
minute
that could be worse
foreign
that's so weird
what just happened
a point and play the resignation gambits
oh that's what happened
that might explain why I was getting
completely out of played
oh it happened mid game too I guess that
doesn't happen too often
interesting
uh did every move just match the engine
I guess it did
is Knight G7 top engine move
okay it's one of the top
oh kudos to lichas for being super super
prompt
yeah I was getting completely crushed
wow
okay I guess that's why I couldn't find
anything like
like I was gonna play an ic7 at first it
looks crushing for white the problem is
94.
or apparently Queen D4
and then
yeah if I play Knight H3 there's an 82.
okay
well thank you leechas for
supervising the games being very prompt
there
yeah this should go without saying but
if you're gonna
play chess online
uh Playfair don't use that engine
uh
because you will get caught eventually
or immediately
okay it's Gambit time
uh I have to keep up with my list I
haven't played the Stafford yet
ooh can I play lukini
I'm gonna preserve the F Pawn bush
what is this
what is this Knight E2
I think I'll play this okay it's reverse
king's Gambit
or reverse Vienna Gambit because my
Knights developed
and now D5 and there's no Queen H5
because the knight's in the way
so it's maybe already improved
okay this looks Pleasant
I gambited but I won back the pawn
a really nice development here
all minor pieces developed
I'll try and watch my time a bit more
carefully
also thinks it's juggle the first time
Prime sub
I want to do fun things
I think I'll start with this and then
just Castle
yeah I have the bishop here now
and night is enjoying life
this would lose the queen to Knight C2
Wayne has to move back to one of these
squares
I'll keep improving
I really want to take on G3
but
I don't see how it works
so maybe I'll reposition the light to F4
oh thank you pass pong quadruple nine
yeah uh the streamlabs alerts are down
but I do appreciate all the subs and
resubs
okay a lot of potential targets here
that's some nice coordination the pieces
looking for The Knockout below
like takes
maybe Queen G4
threatening this
Rook H4 maybe Queen G7
keeping the battery
still threatening to take
I think taking on F2 would destabilize
oh D4
trying to destabilize my position
lingering tension here
okay
play solidly
I'm waiting for some opportunity like
maybe a five not sure though
prove the bishop
wow okay black is the one who sucks
or white someone who sucks
having color identity issues
okay now I can take
and win a pawn
maybe win another Pawn
there's Rook G1
I'll move back
up the exchange up on time
okay
another one down
so what have I not played yet still
haven't played the staff right now
played the more uh
Jerome Atkinson
I think I'll keep playing E4
oh tracks are too yeah
oh let's play a Tennyson
it was between Tennyson and Blackmore
Diemer
I guess like this is one way to kind of
decline the Tennyson
oh this isn't really a Gambit type
position at all but I tried
I think this is a pretty standard like
queenless middle game position though
it's very positional
I do have a4s to gradually grab space on
the queen side
boxing space on the king side
I do want to play B4 maybe B5
might require a little bit of
Preparatory moves
I think I'll go for Rook B1 and then
like B5 and just try and get a an attack
against box King
take it with I'll take my Bishop
so even though we traded Queens early
uh I'm still playing aggressively
actually all the pieces could
potentially come into play
I take the knights
I might just play Bishop F1
I didn't see a clear
combination there
creating the pawn idea Knight B6 as well
Knight B6 King B8
that's close
feels really close
takes takes Bishop A6 yeah this looks
pretty good
so if King B I'd take in Vision A6
controlling g8s
yeah I didn't win anything but the
position seems really really nice
because I can take over the G file
hopefully
oh what to do
this move hitting the Rook or hitting
the bishop with my Rook
it's still equal material but I have the
two Bishops and I have
what what else do I have
some infiltration Rook beasts Rook G6
with kind of a shish kebab on the sixth
rank
yeah this is really close to winning
something
still not quite though
blocks completely tied down
I'll win the pawn
uh this move is coming
Bishop F6
fighting Rook H7
oh that's all alive though
it feels close to getting mated but
thankfully I'm not getting mated
I have this move too
Rook H6
okay I'm definitely winning something
here
uh what to do take
okay
I was mate next or no it was King A4 it
was made very soon though
okay
yeah both tells Gambit maybe I'll save
that for the final game
to sack my queen
depending who I'm playing
okay uh I'm white
I mean I'll play E4 again maybe go for
um
let's try this Tennyson thing again
like D3
it's like D3 Knight F3
yeah this
okay so this is accepted these are the
two most common moves on Lee chess
both of them run into funny tactics
yeah there you go
oh no box Queen
wait a minute did I mess this up die
messed it up there's force made after
Queen H5
I forgot I studied this yesterday
it's still completely winning though
okay
I think there's like made in six or
something right
I literally had this position on
on stream like just an analysis last
night yeah it's made in six
so Queen H5
and then Queen G6 then we oh we sacked
the bishop
and if they take it it's mate
as they move here
where's we made Queen E4
ah Queen B4 maze
it's a nice finish
okay that was fun
do most people fall into this
wow most people fall into this
13 000 people played Knight of six
walking into Knight takes F7
that's really nice
because the two most common moves for
black in this position
both walk into this trick yeah the top
move is the Nike side this works it's
very hard to play White's winning the
queen
uh it's so nice to get this the day
after analyzing
but next time I'll I'll remember the
maiden six
oops that's on mute oh I'm playing chess
Prince
okay I'll play uh I'll play this Alvin
counter grounded
but there's a cool line
I think 97.
this is like a new idea I think
but I forget the idea
what's the idea
there's about five Bishop G4 maybe
Knight C6
I know there's some line where you like
you're supposed to trade Queens this
move was played in the World Cup
I think musi took against Tong Zhang Yi
like one of the semi-final matches
it's weird to like go for the queen
trade when you're down the pond but
there's some idea to Target C2 of course
E5 is still a Target as well
oh yeah maybe chessweed has uh talked
about this before
actually I first learned this from uh
college teammates
Alexander shimanov
who's showing this once
okay I hadn't developments and just
wanting to win back upon
Bishop F4 is prevented
maybe I can take
um
maybe just us
there's about four maybe coming
or not
yeah Bishop B5 is a good move
okay offering the night trade
this does allow F3 F3 Bishop E6
Knight moves I win E4
I'm still very tricky
and still has a lot of Gambit vibes
oh that's a good move
Bishop's coming in
played this move
take take
let's try it
or maybe I can just get the bishop pair
time is good
um it's one of the benefits of playing a
very oppy opening
and cause my opponent to use more time
in the opening
so I have the bishop pair Knight E3
probably Rook here
foreign
go for uh this move
uh four is coming though maybe this move
keeping an eye on the pawn
hmm
okay hitting the knights
still not great
everything Bishop B5
foreign
doing on A4
that's kind of just chilling actually
oh no should not have allowed that
really
I've only got two passive here
what's happening not a rook
I'm up two rocks
okay
that was a funny game
I was probably in a lot of trouble there
it was interesting opening though
uh album counter gambits
I mean there's no time but uh real quick
we can see 97
it's been played a handful of times
including my dubov a Master Level play
yeah muzi choke against tan Zhang Yi
actually I photographed the players in
that game at the World Cup in Sochi
okay
keep going
ah how do I Gambit against this move
let's play this
oh new opening
uh D4 I'll just play like a Danish
wait how do I do this
play this
I used to do this and then win the queen
I just gambited both Center Pawns
that's really dubious
thank you chicken Isa
okay so if takes I win the queen
probably not gonna happen though
if E5 maybe Queen B3 that's kind of cool
yeah this defends the queen
so
what to do with this move
I just have to accelerate development
ooh
there there
I want to do it it doesn't work though
I think I should just Castle
maybe we'll see this move
targeting the bishop and pinned Knights
yeah East looks very safe
okay I'll Target the bishop
yeah 95 might be coming
before
maybe before an A4
is interesting
is Queen G3 first
I'm looking at 95 Bishop B5 C6 Queen G3
I'm not sure what to make of this
it's probably really dubious
ah
it's actually a good move
Bishop D6 is coming
so what to do
F4
F4 is in the error
ooh
so I'm down two Pawns
pawns defended three times also attack
three times
I'm kind of trapping in my own Bishop
but the idea is still play H5 next
going full Attack Mode
Alpha zero Style
got the battery
okay so I'm threatening to take and then
Queen F6
or take take and then Queen F6
attention's mounting
so I think
it was better work
no the Queen's still
take
hmm
another five coming
it's still interesting though I'm just
losing like most of my Pawns
maybe G4 soon
foreign
Queens but I might have to
yeah I kind of have to
wow
What's Happening Here
's a funny line
oh it doesn't work though
oh no
I'm actually in trouble okay
now I'm in less trouble
box completely suck here
but how do I make progress
oh I guess I went on time
so what that could have done was play
Rook f8 check
where's the trader Rooks play King F7
and then
I think against a strong player I would
have lost that
even despite the time situation
anyway uh next game starting
we gotta save the craziest Gambit for
the end whatever that may be
maybe I'll like just combine as many
gambits as possible towards end
so this is a penultimate game
um
I mean gotta do England right so one
one thing that's left
I'll play
um I'll go for this D6 line it's kind of
interesting
Queen D7 castling
foreign
it's already looking nice
let's start with this
let me start with Knight F6
I guess white wants to Castle Queen side
too
and queen E2 might be oh
now I can play G5
like a g
the idea is very simply to play G4
and destroy the king's side get the Rook
to g8s
etc etc
thank you poison pain live
also thank you Murphy appreciate the
subs
was there a raid
oh there was a grade thank you thank
your thinker teacher
appreciate that
yeah streamlabs alerts are broken but uh
as I can still see it in chat
okay let's take and play G4
now that they can move
but okay
I could also say where it is
yeah this is looking really fun because
I have the G file I got the Bishops
pointed towards the king queen can come
into play
I might start with a move like Queen E6
just to maneuver to H6
wow
that's a bold decision I think I can
play F5 here
because if Bishop D3 I win the queen
otherwise I win the bishop
thank you Boro buga
yeah this is
this is pretty much Gigi
I wouldn't be surprised if white resigns
here
I maybe is there any fight left
oh there's some fight left I'm still
writing this
um now I can play this move
and the problem for white is if the
queen moves away from the thing the
Knight I take it
because of the pin if Queen D5 I win the
queen again
yeah Checkmate is imminent
that was a pretty nice England Gambit
uh yeah this this G6 line I think it
offers more long-term compensation
there's other lines in the England with
more like clear traps but this was more
just a nice attacking setup
and especially with opposite opposite
sized castling and G4
um the G4 Pawn break was really nice
so
okay
gotta Save The Best For Last
what should I do
bong cloud boatas
Jerome
I'm playing Ronaldo aguara something
okay I'll go for a Jerome
dough No Jerome okay I'll gamble all my
Pawns
we're repeating this
D4
Queen D4 novelty okay I don't want a
queen trade
let's play Queen H5
wait this is just a really bad opening
for me Queen G5
I feel like I'm playing like a beginner
it gives me some nostalgia
yeah I could move I have this move
I'm violating so many opening principles
I feel like at some point I'm gonna bow
ties Gambit
okay I want to play C3 next
Chase's Queen away
maybe when the night
foreign
s
and maybe a rook
does that work
that looks fun
I am I'm straight up sacking a rook
take my Rook
it might work
but it might not
oh no my Rook
okay what more can I get it
and there's Bishop B5
maybe this move first
I'm just down the Rook here but I'm
threatening to trap the queen
and a queen might be hard to trap
let's play this
idea Queen C4
oh
I really don't want to trade Queens
that's a really annoying move
because I wanted I wanted to both as
Gambit but it's not gonna work I'm down
the Rook
yeah that's a really good move
I'm playing that three
baby
okay
so I'm down the Rook I'm down on time
I've sacked enough
now it's time to try and come back
H4 incoming
ooh
light squares are very tender
B4
if I want to attack on the queen side
not so simple though
play B5 soon
it might be three first
that's a good move can I take on these
seven remind me later
take
no okay let's gather the pawn
is opening the file
and now this move
stop hurting me
stop it
stop it
oh my Rook
okay it's all part of the Gambit
there's a funny umpassan Chuck
not quite amplus on checkmate
not even quite anything
oh no my Bishop
how do I stalemate myself
that's not even stalemate did I win that
I won that
oh it's a clutch Pawn
it's checkmating material
wow
what a way to finish the tournament
I gambited everything
except the H Pawn
okay
it's a beautiful ending
I feel kind of bad for my opponents
we'll call that the everything Gambit
okay well I hope people enjoy that I'll
probably put that on YouTube
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
let me know if you made it this far
also let me know what your favorite
candidate was
I know I didn't get to all the gamuts I
wrote previously
but these are the gamuts that I played